I am waking up at the night with pins and needles in my fingers and it mostly goes away, but
during the day, I'm still having a bit of numbness in my fingers. When my car pressure
adjusts my neck, I feel it in my fingers, so I figure it must be my neck going out, but
his adjustments aren't holding any suggestion. Number one, I'm very, very, very parole car
practice for cancer patients, but make sure your car practice is doing low force adjustments.
There's a lot of car practice. A lot of car practice are, you know, a car practice adjustment
is going to cure everything and you just need to get adjusted and they ignore the fact that you
have cancer that possibly might have the testicist at the testicized to the spine and then an
adjustment could fracture a vertebrae quite easily and cause serious, serious damage. So A,
make sure that car practice is doing low force adjustment, hopefully activator. B, make sure
the car practice is getting adequate x-rays and see, remember that even if the car practice took
x-rays and says, I don't see any metastasis to the spine, that the simple radiological fact that
you have to have over 50% bold loss to see bold loss on x-ray. So say that again, if you don't have
really a 40% bold loss for metastasis to the spine, you may not see it until it's over 50%.
So just because they take x-ray and it looks clean does not, in my opinion, give any car practice
or the right to do manual adjustments to your neck. So just be careful of that. If they're really a
gentle adjuster to a gentle, gentle manual adjustments, that's fine, but it concerns me that when
adjusts you, this phrase concerned me, when you said, when my car practice adjusts my neck,
I feel it in my fingers. That concerns me a little bit. So just be careful of that.
Honestly, most likely the pins and needles in your fingers have to do,
wake it up in the morning with that has to do with poor sleeping posture. Your neck is in a position
where it's kind of throwing your spine out of place. Think about getting a car practice pillow
from your car pressure that will hold your neck in place a little bit better. Give it your neck
support. You need to have a 35 to 45 degree curve from a lateral
side picture in your neck. And if you don't have that, if your neck is creaked up at all,
you're going to be impinging the spinal nerves and causing, you know, the neuropathy that way.
So it could be definitely could be a structural problem. And, you know, if your adjustments
aren't holding, then you have to look at, well, why aren't my adjustments holding? Hopefully,
you're going to a car pressure that's addressing these kind of things. Your bones don't move by
themselves. They move by action of the muscles and they're held together by action of the ligaments.
So, you know, weakness in ligaments is most commonly caused from damage. So you have a whiplash
of some kind, damaging the ligaments. Weakness in the muscles has to do with, you know,
muscle contusion or muscle stretch or muscle damage of some kind. And it can be just chronic
damage from poor posture. So look at your posture. Hopefully your car pressure is doing some
origin insertion work on your scalines, on your
your superspinatus muscles, you know, try to work on those muscles that are supposed to be
holding your vertebrae in place. You know, if not, you know, maybe find a car pressure that does more
kinesiology, applied kinesiology work that can do muscle work on that to work on the reason why
those are going out of place.